how important is our British Military
Support in this war I believe that this
with the United States that the core of
the military equipment support there are
many nations who are helping us some of
these nations within European Union some
of them
Canada Australia for distant Nations but
the core of the assistance coming from
here from this island and from the
United States okay those service to air
missiles that we were looking at there
how important have they been in the war
this is the yet another game changing
equipment you remember in the first
stages we're in laws and anti-tank then
we had to to move up and up the
escalation is going up and we are
catching up with with this trend now
this far region artillery and nowadays
this the the rocket systems which allow
us to reach out 80 almost 100 kilometers
beyond the front lines
um talk to us about what's been
happening um in the course of the
weekend and over the last few days work
was successfully moving up north and now
we changed the direction to South which
allows us you know from time to time to
push the here and go there there are a
new dangerous sports like noso of
Ukraine where Belarus which is a Allied
to Russia is not messing up forces
mostly Russians are coming through it
and the endangering Kiev and northern
part of Ukraine as well Iranian Iranian
drones are becoming very dangerous they
were said setting them against the
civilian civilian cities one small towns
next next to Kia was just hit this this
night
um and do we know what happened as a
result
oh unfortunately people died mostly
civilians the the fire is everywhere but
we were trying to find the uh antidote
against this we understand that they
will have them they have silver Russians
still have a couple of allies like
Northern Korea which recognizes the the
independence of these pieces bits and
pieces they stole from Ukrainian
territory
Iran Belarus but still that this even
these ones in the barriers they're
dangerous
we've seen full referendum and we're
told that the people within that those
areas are voted by more than 90 in order
to become Russian what would you say in
response I've wrote the Putin's remarks
that even he was surprised by higher
turnout and what I remember from what
they have how they conduct the elections
in referendos is the most important part
not to get over 100 percent that's
sometimes they wanted to show the
loyalty to prove the loyalties to his
leader their leader in a way that they
go all over these numbers and again and
people are coming to you with the
kalashnikovs and pointing where you have
to sign that's the result you receive
we've seen some images
um obviously too distressing to show at
this stage
um reportedly showing um gold caps and
teeth
um that were found in a town near to
isium which has just been liberated
suggestions that the teeth that were in
a box in a room was part of a torture
chamber by Russian soldiers what do you
know about it
this is what's happening when we are
free in the cities because Russians
believe we will never get there so there
were committing all the atrocities their
rapes the the killing musculine the
tortures the bearing people together
Mass graves because they thought that
they will cover it for for for from
everybody now we're uncovering more and
more of it that's something we were we
were saying that we have to be ready for
the atrocities committed by these people
in most of the cases they're coming here
because first of all they're criminals
themselves sometimes they've been taken
from from prisons and Russians are just
getting around and bargaining in the
prisons offering the people free ride in
half a year if they survive in Ukraine
so we're not surprised that this
approaches atrocities are happening what
we want to do we want the world to
recognize this and most probably to to
come with the tribunal which would allow
us to go after all these criminals and
political Elite which is pushing this
you know very bad
very bad tribe to Ukraine so do you
think it is um you're suggestion it's
Russian criminals that are carrying out
these atrocities sometimes soldiers
there are some some sometimes the
soldiers but especially when you
mobilize in 300 000 people they do owe
whatever millions of people will come
there's not professionals there's
somebody some of these people are these
very bad record some of them are Flynn
you've seen probably the numbers
hundreds of thousands of young Russians
are trying to flee not to be mobilized
but some of this I mean really really
strange personalities are getting it and
they're not controlled and I believe
that that's what Putin is actively
promoting they're trying to scare us of
our our civilians and our militaries but
this Unthinkable things which are coming
from I don't know centuries ago are you
completely comfortable that Ukrainian
soldiers always behave in an appropriate
manner I'm not I'm not 100 sure that
everybody is behaving 100 pure and
that's one of the problems we have to
keep our people and that's what we were
saying from the very beginning to our
own people we have to win at the same
time we we cannot become them at the
process we have to have a moral Higher
Ground so if you know something we are
persecuting these people and you know
sometimes when you lose everything all
your family is everything you're getting
back to the forces and you're trying to
you know to to pay the the check so we
have to understand how we keep these
people on the on the total Ukrainian
control command control
where are we as far as investigating war
crimes are concerned
the problem with investigating the war
crimes that we need the international
support with investigators as simple as
that we need people to help us to you
know record all these atrocities
sometimes nations are helping mostly
they're promising to come but this is a
matter of time when we if you cannot
record this if you cannot prove that
this authorities were committed in the
months they will be too late we won't be
able to prove and we want to have a
purely International open process not
just ukrainians everybody I know that
I've seen the French prosecutors and
instigators in Ukrainian grounds already
we had initial conversation with your
people we're still still there we will
still have to you know I understand it
is still war it is a very active
military campaigners we don't want to
put people in the danger but in the
places where we're already freed that
all of these atrocities all this was
happening we have to have somebody to
help to come and show even even media to
show that this is these activity is
outgoing and have you received support
from the British in that regard
it was discussion initial that you would
send people who knowledgeable people
investigators who would be able to come
and help us record this last time I
checked it so already was was still in
the in the stage of of agreements so
what would you say to the British
government about I would like them to
find a way to send the investigators as
as French did
and that would be an appeal directly to
um our president our prosecutor General
was was talking to the to the
prosecutors here we had a visit to
Minister of Justice Just this Monday
we're discussing with just a secretary
the same I understand that the changes
of government they are not helping
promote many many of these projects many
of them were put on hold so we were
trying to you know get back to the
attention of for authorities How
concerned are you about nuclear weapons
um the President says he's not joking
he's not bluffing first of all did
somebody saying that's not bluffing most
probably they are blotting and I
understand that the this is one thing
about the nuclear weapons that many
people believe that we have to stop
right now whenever we are and do
whatever putting wants from from us
because it is so so dangerous for the
whole planet we understand we realize if
anybody in this world understands was
nuclear disasters ukrainians maybe
Japanese so we do know that don't have
to be told what what we're also
observing in our papers
those people actually are discussing how
to survive the nuclear blast where to
call if you will send your kid to school
and kindergarten and then there was
nucleus track where to find all these
live hacks how to survive the best so
people I actually discuss which is quite
strange I mean even observing from these
peaceful Nation it's quite strange that
people are actually discussing this but
Ukraine is prepared even for such a
horrible event
I just when I was just as in a sidebar I
was when I was reading the news about
what happened in Thailand I saw that you
were shaking your head in dismay I just
cannot believe you know that something
is always happening now on such a level
of atrocity that somebody's just coming
to kill we were surviving they're trying
to survive or half a year and in some
other nations people just come in and
killing kids we all lost more than 400
of kids already
thank you very much for joining us
always thank you a pleasure to see you
thank you very much indeed